on a tous un sosie animal ça c'est vrai
nous parle aider les vivants c'est à
dire vraiment un animal qui nous
ressemble
ils n'ont regardé passer donc simplement
parce que génétiquement parlant on est
lié à tous les animaux ça vous amène ont
tous un dernier ancêtre commun
ah oui bien sûr moi mon en fait je sais
c'est un lion oui pas l'animal la barre
chocolat les bogdanov des tweaks on a le
sosie de vladimir poutine
regardez ce qui bouge car on a donc
choisi de céline dion regardez ces
lignes on regarde regarde regarde et
très franchement aimerait mais là c'est
une blague il peut vraiment y avoir un
rapport c'est les mêmes non c'est non je
blague on est d'imiter lyon et si oui
tout l'édifice peut laisser briques par
tout ce qui vit sur cette planète est
liée à bien sûr d'un point de vue
génétique notamment aux dernières êtres
vivants commun qui remonte à près de 4
milliards d'années une bactérie on est
tous issus de cette bactérie
dorothée a dérivé vers des végétaux
ensuite des animaux des animaux complexe
d'animaux plus simple et on a un dernier
ancêtre commun il ya quelques millions
d'années simplement avec le gorille par
exemple donc on est bien évidemment
complètement lié aux chiens ou chats
sauvages aux cochons mémo fleurs un épi
de maïs concours ont regardé regardez il
ya céline et son fils regarde et céline
et son fils
on va pas faire céline dion deux heures
non après avoir déjà rihanna qui a aussi
un alain sommes regardés créa là c'est
un truc vous regardez à john travolta
john travolta regard c'est un truc
c'est le même âge et le même gars il est
votre regard des années miley cyrus se
gagneront pas voilà c'est tout la langue
quand même à pousser beaucoup là alors
un jeu celui de trump il est énormément
ignorons c'est le même gars alors j'ai
également trouvé le solide certains
chroniqueurs regardez j'ai par exemple
isabelle morini bosc
non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez regardez il est mignon le j1 et
me regarde et on a également on
également benjamin castaldi
regardez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un sosie animalier de moi version tête
de suspense c'est pas magnifique